fabre une gazelle qui lance c'est normal
ajoute au pis les animaux ont les mêmes
préoccupations que nous salaire mais non
c'est une nouvelle appli dommage ces
sites jeudi la nouvelle voisine en
évoluant c'est comme ça on s'excuse pas
rod fanni c'est léon ne refroidit
personnes le jour de mon mariage
[Musique]
m
soit
je suis
je m'appelle gazelle bienvenue à s'auto
pis
[Musique]
dans qu'est ce que c'est beau les
moutons et les jeux mais l'approché
d'apple doit toucher la lettre à moto
ont tué la part pas dans quel quartier
avait quartier de la forêt tropicale
entre wein et tonga regarder les caméras
de surveillance de tout allié tout ça
est passionnant à vrai dire parce que le
3 février vous avez de plus été rarement
des choses si excitant longtemps vous
êtes l'adjointe au maire deux autopsies
dont je ne fais que du secrétariat
améliorée je pense que le maire voulait
obtenir le vote des moutons mais il m'a
offert cette jolie tu as choisi un petit
surnom rigolo qui m'a donné une fois moi
je les appelais prout de lyon une fois
il n'a pas du tout apprécié j'ai
vraiment passé un sale quart d'heure oui
monsieur
allez je me saoule vous me direz si vous
trouvez quelque chose c'était vraiment
chouette pour moi tu crois que le soir
elles se comptent elles mêmes pour
s'endormir titouan
johanna si le lieutenant mike horn on a
un cambriolage mais j'essaierai
identifié une plaque plage ce type le
plus rapide là dedans tu as besoin d'un
truc vi nations
ajoutez quelques départs et c'est quoi
tu veux dire que parce que c'est un
paresseux il peut pas être rapide flash
rapide qu'une flèche pour gâcher content
de te voir ravid de devoir aussi les
teneurs du diop police comment ça va
disons que je vais bien
bien que accroche-toi puis-je faire
et bien j'espérais que vous puissiez
vous eh bien j'espère est aujourd'hui et
bien j'espérais que vous puissiez
identifié une plaque pour nous et on est
vraiment super préfet qu'elle est le
numéro 29
tu es de la plaque 29th des 03 20
[Musique]
9 thd 03 et 03 des vertes orange c'est
rocco est flash je te raconte une bien
bonne
d'accord alors quels mots qualifie une
chamelle à trois bosses je sais pas
enceinte
ah ah ah
c'est amusant très amusant est ce qu'on
pourra se concentrer et la wii flash
quels mots galifi williams elle a trois
bosses
ok on a compris la nouvelle
il faut éviter l'heure de pointe et tous
les personnages sont attachants et sont
importants il n'y a pas de petits
personnages
[Musique]
salut c'est fred testot bons joueurs
feront trancheront bonjour tout le monde
c'est thomas ngijol
bonjour c'est pascal elbé alias le chef
beaucoup saluent ces isa de mary fils à
lui s'était dit riner saluer ses looks
mag orient ça vous arrive d'aller des
mecs qui veulent pas quitter le plateau
encore j'ai la chance de prêter ma voix
à vélo wever non monsieur vous avez une
réunion très importante qui commence
tout de suite alors si je pouvais tout
en haut
elle est très pécs et elle a beaucoup
beaucoup d'énergie elle est très drôle
moi benjamin cloud the te lui que tout
le monde prend pour un flic enrobé qui
adore les baigner juste en train de te
stéréotypé et généreux et gentil et
jovial enfin il exactement comme moi en
fait le personnage de yack 100
personnages très cool hein
bah oui on est dans un club de
naturistes on n'est pas des pigeons
interprète le personnage de gazelle qui
est une pop star
otto piller est un endroit unique je
prête ma voix un tout petit fennecs avec
une très grosse voix le 17 février le
chef boubou ses limites
secundo nous accueillons parmi vous de
nouvelles recrues que je devrais vous
présenter mais je ne le ferai pas parce
que on sentait une espèce de bourg et au
grand coeur combien ça c'est assez
ces médications oui mon chéri c'est très
bien d'avoir des rêves alors moi je
double boni une maman lapine une carotte
à la fois c'est une aventure ébouriffant
pour les petits mais aussi pour le grand
alors toi aussi
viens voir zutopi prenez-vous donc pas
traîné après vite
ciao voilà vous êtes prévenus zutopi
vous n'aurez jamais rien vu d'aussi poil
à
next
oui un peu
au grain
[Musique]
la nouvelle vient de tomber la police
deux autres qui a commencé à enquêter
sur des secrets dissimulés dans un autre
pays j'espère que vous avez une bonne
excuse
ouvrons notre premier dossier concernant
des références cachées à d'autres films
et à d'autres personnages disney aussi
connu sous le nom de clin d'oeil
nous étions allés à 100 francs sociaux
dans les nouveaux héros qui est aussi la
ville du mois sur le calendrier de bogo
bien que nous n'ayons aucun témoignage
de mickey lui même si vous utilisez
votre loupe vous pourrez le trouver ici
parce qu'il est partout dans ce film
dans la toundra ville il y a des
références à la reine des neiges tout au
long du film on se sent libéré des
livres et vous avez peut-être déjà noté
le signalement c'est de la jeanne
courageuse et portons les roct amenas et
pentaho et ben salah découvrez d'autres
temps des scènes coupées et d'autres
bonus top secret
c'est tout pour le moment entre
surveiller la sortie prochaine deux
autos pillon blu ray d achat digital
[Musique]
ça va tout le monde est si on a trois
sujets importants
primo la d'entre eux donnent aux cavs
quelque chose et je ne me trompe
francine jouer les anniversaires
nous accueillons parmi nous de nouvelles
recrues que je devrais vous présenter
mais je le ferai pas parce que on sent
qu'on est enfin nous avons quatorze
dossiers de mammifères disparus que des
prédateurs
ça va d'un ours polaire géant à une
toute petite loutre la mairie me casses
les gangs quand on retrouve ceux qui ont
disparu
c'est la priorité numéro un
souto pis une ville est insolente où les
animaux de toutes espèces prédateurs
comme proies vivre ensemble en paix et
en harmonie besoin jésuite jeudi
daterait nouvelle voisine on est
brillante c'est comme ça on s'excuse pas
le premier l'a pas officier de la police
de s'auto pie xii il est prêt à rendre
le monde meilleur
mauvaise nouvelle en provenance de cette
ville marquée par la peur que
pouvez-vous nous dire sur les animaux
devenus sauvages et ton en danger c'est
la priorité numéro un
stationnement c'est je ne suis pas là
pour faire la potiche si vous échouez
vous démissionnez
moi je suis venu vous poser quelques
questions pour une enquête il aurait dû
engager un vrai flic pour le retrouver
je vous arrête pourquoi parce que je te
fais que si vous êtes un témoin
essentiel
non c'est lui 28 c'est cette plaque
d'accord je connais la tipp quand tu as
besoin d'un truc il assure que t'es pas
récent il faut qu'on travaille ensemble
pour résoudre les enquêtes ce n'est que
trente six heures il s'agit pas de
vouloir absolument quelque chose il
s'agit avant tout d'en être capable je
suis un vrai flic ne jamais montrer
comptable et c'est vous les lapins vous
êtes tellement émotif
on peut être évoluer mais autour de soi
qu'on reste toujours des animaux arrête
tu vas décor junior il est tenu bien sûr
on a tous bien jusqu'en bas
la vie est un peu compliqué
[Musique]
on fait tous des erreurs à peu importe
quelle source d'hannibal vous êtes le
changement commence avec vos
opportunités acquis la voiture est la
partie on parlera du crime mr bean
c'est lui mr big qu'est ce qu'on avait
dit on ne refroidit personnes le jour de
mon mariage je dois le faire mon bébé
papa doit le feu